I just want to start by saying how much
I enjoyed the show I thought it was so
well done and I speak for all fans after
they finished the 8th episode by saying
when can I see season 2 haha I don't
know I have no idea do you do we does
anyone know they haven't started
shooting it yet hell no these are things
that need to change I mean I need to get
the next episode into the band so I'm
just I'm throwing that out there
my characters done so I have no
information about the next i I've
learned with Ryan anything is possible
oh yes I know that yeah they come back
from the dead and everything else I know
oh you know I'm I guess what was it like
wait because you've worked with Ryan
obviously a number of times but what was
it like that first time meeting Ryan for
you and I'm curious what was it like for
you meeting Ryan for this and how much
is it like are you in your head the
night before thinking should I kind of
impressed I got to make sure I get this
I last minute somehow convinced him to
see me in New York so I took a red-eye
to New York and I hmm
like I just I had like an hour to be
with him in New York and I am I wore a
fluffy Hanukkah sweater and I had a baby
blanket and I drew a turkey hand and the
audition I just was like I just gotta
throw it all against the wall and see
what sticks and it was very receptive
and and and yeah it was I was I was
scared of course but I think what's cool
what was fun at least in the audition
was the space and the freedom to explore
something really out there and
heightened because I know he isn't
afraid of that sort of thing like he's
such a brilliant writer and he goes
there that I didn't have to be like I
wonder if he can you know he's like has
such a vast imagination I don't know now
I'm rambling I don't know thank you
thank you I was looking for that
validation Thanks
for you you obviously broke with Ryan a
number of times but what was it like
those initial things when you first met
him and because you obviously have
maintained such a great relationship
yeah long enough ago it's hard to
remember but I mean it was always easy
with Ryan we got along really well right
from the beginning I mean you know it's
never 100% smooth sailing with Ryan we
had like falling outs here and there
along the way but it there's like
something at the core of the
relationship that kind of you know is it
somehow sustains you through good times
bad times long time was it so I mean it
you know it's been a wonderful working
relationship with him and he directed
the first episode of the first season
that I did and I found him to be a
really really great director you know
like just setting the direction right
away and I got it and then you know from
there on we worked really easily
together one of the things that I really
respect about Ryan and commend is his
commitment to inclusion and diversity
both in front of and behind the camera
can you sort of talk about that aspect
of Ryan and what it means to you also
well I know with his you know his
program the 50-50 where like every you
know it has to be 50% women on the crew
directing I mean it's you know he was
doing the thing about Ryan is that he
always seems to prefigure what's coming
up ahead you know there's something
uncanny about him so this he put into
works before the you know before a lot
of the movements became public and
national he already had these things in
place where he wanted to be
50 percent every man that was there
would be a woman in that same you know
in the capacity so I mean with directors
with crew members with everything I
think so yeah I mean I think he's you
know he's always ahead of the curve
somehow yeah I think you know with great
power comes great responsibility and he
respects that and honors that in a way
that I so commend he cares so much about
implementing this structure on every
single one of his sets and for him to be
as powerful of a figure as he is and to
be successful and with in doing this is
um a testament to what a cool person he
is and again how much he cares
I would imagine making this show you
guys have some great scenes together and
there's some great moments in all eight
episodes but was there a scene or
sequence that you were really excited to
film or really nervous to film when you
got the script there so bonkers fun I
was super excited about shooting um how
to give too much away but there's a
scene where I am I'm not living at home
anymore and I felt like it was the you
know infinity has been infantilized
for you know her whole life and she kind
of gets a taste of freedom and she has a
ton of questions that come with that
freedom and it's the first time they
started to really engage in this power
struggle of what's really going on yeah
I loved our scenes together I mean they
were funny and they were outrageous and
yeah I mean it was working with Zoe was
really easy there was a natural rhythm
and
and kind of a shared Sensibility and an
approach to work because sometimes you
can be working with an actor whose
approach is so diametrically opposed to
the way you come into a scene but we got
really lucky because we I mean we just
found a way that was natural and easy
for both of us to work and I think that
opened up a lot of possibilities you
know I mean a lot of ways to explore it
because we didn't have to go through
that kind of preliminary elementary
steps to find out how we were going to
work together we just kind of started
and that was it there was a very natural
way of doing it thank you so much for
your time
congratulations on the show cannot wait
for season 2 thank you